civile fait rage en Éthiopie :
un pays delqlqlque 115 millions
d'habitants et de plus de
80 ethnies.
spécialiste Corne d'Afrique
sqsqsqsqu'à maintenant, il y a
toujours eu un homme fort qui
dominait le pays, appuyé sur un.
Jamais ces 80 ethniesse sont rén
ou d'une autre pour décider
par quelles institutions
par quel système vivre ensemble.
- Un conflit armé oppose
le gouvernement fé
d'Abiy Ahmed et le FLPT,
le Front de libération
du peuple du T
Le Tigré, une région
de l'extrême-nord de l'Éthiopie,
qui compte
de la population.
Une guerre fratricide,
mais
contre le fédéralisme
et deux camps qui campent
su- C'est ça qui est aujourd'hui
en jeu : les tenants d'un côté
d'un système centralisé,
en disant : "Il n'y a que
nous réussirons à tenir
le pays", et ça, c'est
la position d'Abiy Ahmed, le
premier ministre, et de l'autre,
moyen de continuer à vivre
mbmbmbmbmble, c'est une très foe
décentralisation, un fédéralisme
autonomie régionale."
- Le FLPT a renforcé
d'une alliance de
neuf organisations rebelles
différentes : une alliance
contre le premier ministre
"Rien ne nous antntntntntntntns
tigréens, qui accuse le premier
ministre de mobiliser le peuple
contre son mouvement.
tigréens ont repris le contrôle
rrrrrrrrrrrritoire,
s'étendant même au-delà.
Avec l'aide du groupe armé allie
aux portes de la capitaleAdAdAde
serait à double tranchant.
de cette alliance, c'est-à-dire
les Tigréens et les Oromo,
ont entre eux une histoire
et que cicatriser cette histoire
ne va pas être simple.
- DesÉthiopiens sont sortis
dans les rues dans un effort
progouvernemental
de mobilisation.
"L'Éthiopie ne sera pas
désintégrée et ifffffffffffffffe
femme, qui dit vouloir protester
contre les groupes terroristes
et les juntes, "ceux qui nous
ont iiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiiii.
Car le FLPT a été au pouvoir
de 1991 à 2018. Devant la
résurgence des tensions,
et américaine s'activent
en coulisses, tentant de ramener
les deux frères ennemisblblblbls
troupes... tigréennes, qui sontn
arrête immédiatement le blocus.
- Les combats dans le Tigré
ont fait des milliers de mor
de déplacés, plongeant le nordÉe
crise humanitaire.
Selon l'ONU, au moirdrdrdrdrdra
famine au Tigré, où aucune aide
n'a pu parvenir
depuis le 18 octobre.
Ici Yasadadadadadadadadadadadaa